bonjour gérard vespière merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
le kremlin demande donc aujourd'hui à ce
que washington reviennent dans l'accord
pour que téhéran puisse le respecter à
nouveau
de son côté l'elysée annonce également
que l'iran doit respecter le jcp haut
pour que les états unis ils prennent
part à nouveau
comment est-ce qu'il faut interpréter
ses différentes sorties médiatiques
internationales il ya beaucoup de
gesticulations beaucoup de préparation
n'est ce pas les l'iran a annoncé
qu'elle se préparait à augmenter son
enrichissement d'uranium
donc cela fait partie des éléments de
négociation
l'iran ne dis pas qu'elle avait commencé
déjà à enrichir n'est ce pas donc il y a
beaucoup de flexibilité il y as besoin
de rencontre il y as besoin de parler à
n'oublions pas que les précédents
accords celui de vienne donc du 14
juillet 2015 a nécessité à peu près deux
ans et demi de négociations a pour se
mettre en place
donc là à nouveau on aura besoin de
temps et n'oublions pas également qu'il
y à de nouvelles élections
présidentielles en iran dans quatre mois
donc et les peu probable qu'il y ait des
avancées significatives avant cette date
les états unis et un temps alors qu'ils
en ont besoin de connaître qui sera
président mais quand vous dites il faut
du temps combien de temps selon vous
pour trouver une résolution pacifique
diplomatique à ce conflit qui dure
depuis mai 2010 huit ans le rappel
depuis que donald trump a déchiré en ce
fameux pacte ce fameux accord de vienne
signer en 2015 le jc perreault a alors
les etats-unis ont un point de vue un
petit peu différent de ce que vous venez
d'expliquer ils ne disent ils disent
qu'ils ne sont pas sortis de l'accord
d'un point de vue juridique mais qu'ils
ont pris des dispositions différentes
donc voilà c'est quelque chose qu'on a
besoin de savoir de comprendre pour
analyser la situation générale sur 7 sur
ce document est sur ce projet combien de
temps bien écoutez je viens de citer la
durée de l'accord des négociations pour
l'accord précédent deux ans et demi donc
là on a besoin
- de recadrer le programme nucléaire on
a besoin d'aborder comme le demande à la
fois washington et l'europe la question
des missiles balistiques on a besoin
d'aborder comme le demande washington
l'europe et aussi la russie deux des
activités iraniennes à l'extérieur de
l'iran n'oublions pas que la dîmière
poutine en 2018 a dit que la situation
syrienne se résoudrait politiquement
avec le départ de toutes les troupes
étrangères et alexandre la frontière le
responsable des négociations avec la
syrie a dit là l'iran y compris donc il
y as besoin à un moment d'un départ des
milices à iranienne de syrie vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure de l'enrichissement
d'uranium
on sait que téhéran s'est désengagé en 2
ans 1 2 puis le retrait américain de
2018 de nombreux points et annoncé donc
récemment l'enrichissement de son
uranium comme vous l'avez 10 à 20 %
début janvier
liron peut-il faire marche arrière selon
vous même si officiellement on est loin
d'un uranium enrichi pour un usage
atomique inquiet de l'ordre de 80 à 90%
nucléaire militaire
absolument là écoutez moi j'ai qualifié
depuis un an et demi
la stratégie iranienne de la stratégie
des petits pas on est passé d'un accord
donc de trois et demi pourcent
d'enrichissement à 4,6 voyez bon on a
augmenté légèrement aussi les stocks
d'uranium et quand on parle des 20%
il s'agit d'une intention d'enrichir and
n'est ce pas les centrifugeuses
non pas du tout commencé à fonctionner
et à fournir de l'uranium enrichi à 20%
c'est un projet donc tout cela fait
partie des éléments très habile de
négociations l'iran qui a posé également
cette condition préalable à son retour
dans l'accord de vienne
parmi elles la levée totale des
sanctions des compensations financières
ou encore l'exclusion de toute
discussion
de son programme balistique est ce que
tu es en demande trop ou pas assez cela
fait partie de la tactique n'est ce pas
voilà chacun mais des cartes sur la
table en disant plus j'ai de cartes à
négocier et bien meilleur ma position de
négociation va être donc elle est
évident que téhéran se prépare à
négocier plus on met deux cartes sur la
table plus cela veut dire que les liens
là la proximité du tapis vert mais pas
très éloigné comment la russie où
l'union européenne peuvent-elles
influencé pour les états unis reviennent
dans l'accord en gros quelle marge de
manoeuvre de moscou de bruxelles de
paris de londres un même voire même de
pékin les marges de manoeuvre finalement
ce sont celles de l'iran ce que peuvent
faire les cinq plus un espace et de
donner enfin par les états unis
c'est de donner des indications de
donner des conseils de ralentir les
volonté iranienne à tout en sachant qu'
il ya aussi un jeu iranien vis-à-vis de
la politique intérieure iranienne
le fait de durcir la position sur le
nucléaire est bien donne des gages
intérieur politique à l'iran vis-à-vis
de son aile la plus radicale à le majlis
à voter effectivement l'enrichissement à
20%
le parlement iranien donc le majlis a
voté le l'arrêt des visites
d'inspecteurs de l'aiea et bien le
gouvernement iranien a pris des
positions un peu en retrait voyez vous
donc il ya beaucoup de dosage aussi à
l'intérieur du régime
merci gérard vespière d'avoir répondu à
une question je rappelle que vous êtes
analyste expert en géopolitique et
directeur du média web indépendant le
monde décrypté